[Music]
leading up to its premiere on disney
plus marvel studios
loki series was all anyone could talk
about online from all caps tweets
professing intense anticipation for the
show which follows the 2012
variant version of tom hiddleston's loki
after he swiped the tesseract
and disappeared in avengers end game two
fan edited videos and gifs
celebrating the trickster god and all
his mischievousness the internet was all
loki
all the time across the first eight days
of june 2021
then at long last loki debuted on
wednesday june 9th
and expectedly the conversation heated
up even more
twitter was going loco for loki fans of
the marvel cinematic universe were
thrilled to finally be able to see what
happened to the norse god following the
events of endgame
and the bungled time heist at stark
tower during events that initially
transpired in the first avengers film
in short loki doesn't get very far the
time variance authority apprehends him
for messing up the sacred timeline and
if he doesn't bend to their demands
he'll face extreme consequences needless
to say that's not something this version
of loki has ever done for anyone before
this time around hiddleston's character
is looking very different out of his
flashy green and gold ensemble
loki has been through quite a
transformation over the course of the
mcu
evolving from an ambitious power seeker
into a lovable hero with trademark
cutting wit
but one of the biggest transformations
came in thor ragnarok when matt
damon portrayed loki in a dramatic
reenactment of events from
thor the dark world but how does the god
of mischief himself
feel about that for those who may have
forgotten at the beginning of director
taika waititi's thor ragnarok
loki had disguised himself as his
adoptive father odin
lounging about and ruling asgard with a
well
whatever the opposite of an iron fist is
when thor returns to asgard a giant loki
statue is the first thing he sees which
tips him off that some nonsense is afoot
he gently pushes through a crowd of
asgardians to find odin eating snacks
and watching a play featuring lady sith
loki thor and odin in which everyone's
overacting and
loki is portrayed as a faultless martyr
after faking his death in the dark world
sam neal portrays the actor playing odin
in the production with chris hemsworth's
brother
luke taking on the role of thor and matt
damon playing loki who dies in his
brother's arms in a spectacularly
dramatic scene
after it was reported that neil
hemsworth and damon were all seen on the
set of waititi's thor love and thunder
presumably to reprise their roles
tom hiddleston shared his thoughts about
damon's performance as thor's puckish
adoptive brother
and his possible return in the fourth
thor movie hiddleston told decider
well i have no ownership as you know
loki contains multitudes and he contains
matt damon
recalling the first time damon played
loki's theatrical counterpart hiddleston
added
i was so amused on that i can't remember
it was a couple of days on ragnarok when
he came in and did his thing
it was like looking into a very slightly
distorted mirror and his take on the
whole thing was just hilarious
the actor then teased that he quote
can't wait to see what they've been
doing for thor love and thunder
which is about as much confirmation of a
daemon as loki returned as anyone can
hope for
later during an appearance on jimmy
kimmel live hiddleston joked with kimmel
there's a thing where you like you
always bump him from your show right i
feel
kind of like matt's trying to bump me
from my own character
from there he offered up a playful
warning for damon
next time there's a new jason bourne
movie you know
maybe in another reality there's another
there's another jason bourne it might
show up around the corner
for now fans can only speculate just how
much involvement
damon and his fellow norse players will
have in thor love and thunder
but they'll find out for sure when the
movie releases on may 6
2022. meanwhile the first episode of
loki is available to stream on disney
plus
right now check out one of our newest
videos right here plus even more looper
videos about loki are coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one
you